That Time Johnny Carson Accidentally Caused
a Near Month Long Toilet Paper Shortage in
the US
Much like Orson Welles before him, Johnny
Carson once accidentally used his public platform
to incite a public panic.
On this day in history, 1973, Carson started
a near month long toilet paper shortage in
the United States.
In his show, he stated, “You know what’s
disappearing from the supermarket shelves?
Toilet paper…
There’s an acute shortage of toilet paper
in the United States.”
Americans promptly went out and bought up
every piece of toilet paper they could find.
Supermarkets tried to ration it, but to no
avail.
By noon the next day, pretty much all the
nation’s supermarkets were sold out of toilet
paper.
After several days of toilet paper shortages
due to this hysteria, Carson went on the air
to try to explain it had been a joke and apologized.
But because there really was a toilet paper
shortage now and the shelves were almost always
empty of TP at this time, whenever some would
come in, people would buy it all and hoard
it.
This toilet paper shortage lasted a full three
weeks.
Incidentally, in the “panic” (there really
wasn’t one in reality) after Orson Welles’
famous performance of H.G. Wells’ The War
of the Worlds many people tried to sue for
a variety of things, such as for the mental
anguish the broadcast caused due to being
presented as if it were actually happening.
Among all the suits, which were summarily
dismissed, only one person got what he was
asking for.
That person was a black man who had spent
the money he had been saving for a pair of
shoes on trying to escape the invading Martians.
When Welles’ heard about this, he insisted
that the man be reimbursed his shoe money.